so the prize pool is million dollars
three two one I thought fit me that's
what happens what do their they're wild
creatures and you got to treat them with
respect
so we're flying and then again to spin
around and I'm pretty sure that somebody
clicked them from behind
the world drone pre-ind by is by far the
biggest race meet yet the total kitty is
a million dollars with the winning team
laying claim to 250,000 all stumped up
by the United Arab Emirates prize money
for races is normally at least ten times
less than this Familia Nestor Janeiro so
this is a massive step up Matt a big
purse will bring out the best pilots and
the best competition
and that's a lot of what we try and seek
out advice my rights are live for this
excited to be here we start to race some
of the top people in the world and
excited to be in the team with some of
the best pilots in the world 32 teams of
five were invited to race and put up
free of charge dozens more join them of
their own backs
teams have traveled from every corner of
the world not just for the prize money
but for the track we have four four
pilots that will take our from these
start start pods we do have electronic
gates that track all the logos of the
quad but we wanted to set these up
because of course sometimes when you hit
them you'll see some spectacular
crashing
the drones will have to keep right on
the spine of the track that they go to
the left to the right will be getting
penalties we're trying to promote
innovation creativity to push people to
have aircraft that fly longer that fly
faster to have more reliability with the
motors and the propellers to to push the
industry in general the having it be
entertainment is as a huge plus
it's just cherry on the top compared to
commercial quadcopters built for
photography these drones are much
smaller and lighter made to raise it up
to a hundred miles an hour they're
custom-made stripped down for speed
agility and endurance it's a growing
community of tech loving thrill-seekers
young and old some with jobs some with
kids some are still in school I've been
in our be fine millie for two like here
if you fly build set up everything but
for most of them it's more than just a
hobby
tell me nose lines it's got real
potential to get big and I like to see
this very similar to the the Bill Gates
people in the 1970s in Silicon Valley
and also that all those guys these just
a bunch of nerds that are that are
playing around no one really understands
what they're doing but these people that
are doing this understand what the
future is for others here it's an
opportunity to grow their business
amongst their peers poor Kellett or PKS
he's known in quadcopter circles runs
drone X labs as well as running the team
is main business selling drones a year a
half ago there was a dozen decent frames
now there's a 40 decent print that the
word is is that we're looking at a four
billion dollar industry by 2020 after a
full day of qualifying it's time for the
semi-finals
I've been told these gates are made out
of metal some to see if I can break one
it's completely gone there's a pub
station
he fruit like going down here screen
this way too
so basically it just jumbled mess right
into something I mean it's just flat
when you're just looking at squiggly
lines I mean that's
as if the course wasn't tough enough
many also had to battle the new courses
technical problems
for some pilots the race is over one
pilot going through is 15 year old Luke
banister he flies for the tornado ex
racing team because we wanted to support
such a big team we decided to go and get
a sponsor so we went along and we got
tornado energy who are kind of very much
into esports but saw drone racing is an
ex-new quite a big sport the world of
online gaming with its dramatic rise in
viewers generates more than 700 million
dollars a year with similar first-person
viewpoints as a spectator it's not a bad
model the dominant force in Dubai the
black and yellow of tornado is
everywhere they brought 11 teams to
maximize their chances of winning a lot
of the the sponsors are looking at this
market placement no one's really ready
to pop like jump in completely they
wanted to test the water so the world
Rome Prix was like a perfect test for
this final match right now on this
championship three two one thrown here
we go the final
with tornado miles out in front
unexpectedly
everything seems lost final is marred by
more technical obstacles even the
officials aren't sure who's won the
track please award and it's going to
tornado explains Vani UK despite the
chaos tornadoes Luke Bannister comes
through to take the trophy he and his
team will take a victory bonus proving
drone racing isn't just for hobbyists
anymore
it's entered the big leagues